you would have to acknowledge that the
man has handled himself so superbly so
logically and he's he's been such an AK
RIT achill thinker and so level-headed
it's really hard to pin anything on them
and I think proof positive of that I'm
going to start here I want to show you
the clips that the left are circulating
I found these either in HuffPo or
BuzzFeed that they see as victories
against so I want to show you their best
hand where the left is going oh oh Frank
and just nail gorsek so I'm not hiding
from you and showing you the highlight
reel I'm showing you the low-light reel
as far as they're concerned and then
we'll get into a few more more clips
from gorsek but let's start with Senator
Smalley Al Franken this is the one
making the rounds on the leftist
websites you were very politically
active so in light of that I'd like to
ask away pause just pause real quick
just so you know before this we can
pause it right real time senator Franken
was trying to hit him with all kinds of
legalese talking about the absurdity
doctrine and talking about his history
in politics Neil gorsek history and
politics before it was a justice so he
was really trying to corner him we just
couldn't show the 14-minute diatribe
that was delivered before that because I
think this is the most relevant
information and will allow will comment
as we go live okay engineer garland was
treated fairly by the United States
Senate senator a couple of things in
response that if I might going back a
inserted D doctrine argument was never
presented to the court and it usually
applies in cases where there's a
scriveners error not when we just
disagreed with the policy of the statute
so I appreciate the opportunity to
respond there watch when there is a
scribner there scriveners error oh the
two big men from Corsica make it I can't
believe how dumb you are respect to well
now dragon in the whole crap story
interpretation Oh Rama complet got a big
word statutory the Notre Dame Law School
National Institute for trial advocacy
this is a pretty well-known exception oh
yeah there's a plain meaning
I think you can quiet without it I mean
how do you think of that moment where
you try to educate an ivy-league lawyer
on what the law means why did you have
to drag Notre Dame a class it's just he
goes to a pamphlet so here's something
that's important you'll see tries to
start off with legalese try to start off
with legal arguments and you'll see once
that doesn't stick he goes full chanc he
goes full Young Turks full MSNBC and
gets personal and pivots and divots and
pivots and I say that's because this is
this is what the left is sending out as
a highlight I want you to watch for the
pivoting techniques that you now see in
the dance that is the Al Franken Waltz
surd that this man was put given that
choice and then fired for it don't you
think that was absurd Center my heart
goes out to him okay never mind
that my heart is how do you think
Merrick garland was treated by them then
what's inside the kidney judge ten years
ago I have a canon of ethics that
precludes me from getting involved in
any way shape or form in politics reason
why judges don't clap at the State of
the Union oh and why I can't even attend
a political caucus an education here
report information in the equivalent of
a primary okay but I don't think that
this is a is you have to state your
political views that's not what this is
about how a Supreme Court justice who is
nominated by the president is like in
the Constitution and then your pamphlet
I think you're allowed to talk about
what happened to the word a politically
charged question and he just got done
accusing him of being politically
motivated for things he said before he
was a justice involved in politics you
can express an opinion on this senator I
appreciate the invitation but I know the
other side has their views of this and
you your site has your views of it that
by definition is politics okay and I
think senator judges have to stay
outside them I think the world Merrick
garland I think he's an outstanding
judge okay I know I told you what I
think I understand thank you thank you
III don't mean to cut you off with you
in a way of time
hahaha well I think yours is lying out
definitely err Franken never get snooty
with somebody who's smarter than you
let's go through that right away he goes
through legalese he talks with the
attorney doctor he tries to talk about
the plain interpretation and try I don't
remember the legal term of he's talking
about there so he tries to ask gorsek
about this and others trying to corner
him legally he answers legally educates
him on the the Scrivener there a
scribbler a scribbler a lot he gorgeous
- thank you educate him and then as the
education is taking place he goes right
to wait well but why don't you think
about how Republicans Street America
Carlin's we've gone from a factual
argument to an opinion of argument and
then he tries to go back to a factual
argument of his pamphlet and then when
gorsek tries to answer that again he
goes - ok I get I get goes in the one
last ditch his last-ditch effort is can
I get you to trash Merrick garland I
think you'd a fantastic in a walk a lot
of times I go off in the weeds and the
left is Osso and BuzzFeed see this is a
victory I don't know you can't we made
us cry oh geez
you think that was a stellar performance
for Al Franken I'm trying to remove my
bias glasses obviously I'm conservative
I'm open about that but I watched matin
I'm going this is your a material thing
if that's the a material there be
material this one is more popular in the
feminist websites because uh none other
than Diane Feinstein's she tried to
corner him on a question regarding the
second McKenzie's are we no are we doing
that one right now Diane finds these are
the highlights that this is what if you
were reading liberal sites they are
sitting around finding do you agree with
that statement that under the Second
Amendment weapons that are most useful
in military service and sixteen rifles
and the like may be banned
pause and the like is somewhat have it
all hahaha when it comes so I would say
that umbrella of and the like is
probably poison sprayed and like hmm
well let me answer you on second what
[ __ ] are you fitting in and the like
I can ask that first and the like well
we're going to like oh you know ak-47
there
nuclear bombs we'll see hold on that
changes so it's important they always
leave themselves a little rental
backdoor out there she was hoping to but
guess what it didn't work or I'll clip
senator Heller makes clear the standard
that we judges are supposed to apply the
question is whether it's a gun in common
use you're following a that may be
subject to multiple regulation that's
the test as I understand it there's lots
of ongoing litigation about which
weapons qualify under those standards
and I can't prejudge that litigation no
understand you do you agree with his
statement yes or no the same inside of
the Heller decision Justice Scalia's
statement well whatever is in Heller is
the law and I'm a law well it's not a
matter of agreeing or disagreeing
senator respectfully it's a matter of it
being the law and and my job is to apply
and enforce the law even the left visas
as a victory there is only it's because
they are inherently anti-constitutional
of Yetta they are nearly ante
originalist off every answer you can
expect from from gore secures bin this
is the law this is the appropriate role
of a justice this isn't this is what the
Constitution says this is what we're
supposed to do as justices well what do
you think about high-capacity mechs they
don't like yeah that he is actually
constitutionalist because that answer is
so any any lawyer would have to watch
them well that's that's probably the
proper answer any constitutional
historian have to look at that and say
well you know what that's that's
actually the proper answer the left
looks at it and goes he didn't say he
would ban guns
he's a fake it was been and the like
notice he didn't ask for his opinion on
a row v Wade another right right yeah
well justices are not supposed to make
well they're supposed to interpret I
remember when Roberts rewrote Obamacare
essentially making it passed instead of
sending it back like reckon we got all
up in arms they're doing the exact same
thing they want him to make law
basically from the bench in Co just
interpret he's like no I'll just
interpret it all that's not good enough
yeah
it's very important by the way when she
says you need to understand this we've
talked about this in our second
amendment video the hello vs. D CK I
think was it 2008 2006 either Oh 608 or
oh nine the votes against you know hell
vs. DC so basically what it says is that
you have as a private citizen the right
to carry a firearm what's important is
the only legal argument against that
we've talked about this several times it
wasn't about certain weapons for a
magazine ban the only legal arguments
not a message boards that they can be
made the Supreme Court were that
actually don't have to vote against us
because I don't believe that private
citizens have the right to bear firearms
at all it's the only other cert petition
only other interpretation is that
well-regulated militia means State Guard
national it does not mean a private
citizen has a right to own a gun
at all well they say you're crazy
because you're thinking people are
coming for you're coming for your guns
or justices yeah want to come for your
gun so read up on that that that case
it's a very important case and it gives
you great insight as to what the left
actually can argue legally hello vs. DC
very important very important we talked
about that and then finally this is not
one the left of circulating is a victory
but just because he had to eat a big old
pile of crap here's dick durbin trying
to set him up with a question that he
heard somebody say he asked in a class
it it's boiling it doesn't go well for
him so I just want to ask you to confirm
did you ask your students in class that
day to raise their hands if they knew of
a woman who had taken maternity benefits
from a company and then left the company
after having a baby
suppose an older partner woman at the
firm I want you to run your some stories
not like you become pregnant soon are
your choices as a young person you can
say yes tell the truth and not get the
job you can lie maybe get the job you
say no or you can push back in some way
shape or form and we talk about the pros
and the cons in a Socratic dialogue and
senator I do ask for show of hands not
about the question you asked but about
the following question and I asked of
everybody how many of you have
questions like this asked of you in the
employment environment an inappropriate
question about your family planning and
I am shocked every year senator how many
young women raise their hand it's
disturbing to me
and after that Durbin goes or someone
said you remember grasp this figure I
had 200 course lunch break I brought
tuna oh whoa oh so you're saying oh wait
no you're saying exactly would I agree
with rumor it's been a ting to set up
and I will tell you this I know that I
couldn't navigate the minefield that
they're laying form I know none of us
could because I don't have her neck just
rung dick durbin so the how he handled
himself I will say this I didn't know a
ton about gorsek outside of his opinions
on life second amendment that he was a
constitutionalist all of which I liked
but you know it's hard to get a feel for
someone's temperament yeah just reading
his history watching these and I highly
recommend you watch as much footage as
you can I think the guy is a perfect
temperament to be an even-handed judge
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button it's a circular
button now that says subscribe if not
head on over the Young Turks that's
probably more your speed although
they're coming over to [ __ ] we know
you're here watching I can smell you
from here there's also recommended video
box playing right up there you can join
the mug club a lot of credit comm slash
mug Club for daily content so we're not
dependent here on YouTube shank go/no-go
you don't need to stay here this isn't
good for it's bad for your soul